hey marvel fans we're here with amy
pascal this is an incredible movie what
does it feel like to get this off the
ground running
yes it's fantastic people are out people
are excited people love spider-man it's
great so spider-man talking about the
love of spider-man he's so relatable
what makes spider-man so beloved by all
i think because spider-man means
something different to everyone at
different ages in their life you know
when you're a little kid it means one
thing when you're a teenager or
something else and when you're grown up
something else
you know it's a boy who's always
struggling with
being good
and i think we all understand that
we were able to bring the super villains
from previous spider-man into this film
what was that process like it was
fantastic because of course i had worked
with all of them on the other films and
it was really exciting to bring them
back out of your entire spider-man
journey what are you most proud of
tonight
of course i love it amy thank you so
much enjoy the movie thank you so much
[Music]
you